police act getting the start his 24th
start 10 and six on the year 459 era one
and two against the white sox this year
swag and a miss he went fishing and
police act strikes him out two down ryan
in a recent funk he's all for his
previous 14.
swung out a bouncing ball to first
charge behind the bank club by bradley
steps on the bag and the ending is over
michael kopak gets the start today in
game number two
with a breaking ball strike three
one down for kopec three and two
and he struck him out michael kopeck is
feeling really good right now it looks
like there's another breaking ball i
mean it's late it's sharp and right now
it's looking really good yeah that was
live local and late breaking right there
check swing did he yes he did strike
three struck out the side that's a nice
start for michael after an inning from
cleveland nothing nothing
one and two for billy
miss good slider got billy hamilton
suzanne
for the second strikeout driving socks
scoreless three pitches to two outs for
michael kopeck so far in the second
inning and now change from kopeck called
strike three on a slider
six up six down with four strikeouts and
at the end of two from cleveland nothing
nothing
with two away
ace is empty it's adam engel
to left field mercado on the move he
lays out and he kind of got caught in
the middle there it's down and angle
ends up with a double look to me like
he's sort of double clutched on the
thought of the dive and it may have cost
him there well i think what happens a
lot is the outfielders not only left
field but especially center fielders
they played the outfield partially with
their ears
and what mercado couldn't tell was that
this was hit off the end of the bat it's
another change up klisak likes those so
it's hit off the end of the back meaning
it's a big swing however it doesn't go
near as far as he would have thought set
the belt checks the runner comes to the
plate and it's swung on golfed in the
air to shallow left oscar mercado will
make the catch and please sack with a
shutout through three innings we are
scoreless in the middle of the third
from downtown cleveland mike wright
comes on for the 11th time his era of
three and a half there you look at the
numbers he inherits a scoreless ball
game no score third inning indians
looking for their first base runner
kicks delivers and the pitch swung on
line to right and it hits the foul line
fair ball
millard makes the turn he's on his way
to second sliding with a double and he
got on top of a high 93 mile an hour
faster he just threw him an off speed
pitch that's a great job of hitting
right there that goes to show you as a
hitter he might have been looking
breaking paul or whatever he was still
able to get on top of that fastball and
oscar mercado to the plate for the
second time tonight
swinging a fly ball to center hamilton
broke back now he comes in and makes the
catch
and cleveland strands a couple at the
end of three in the nightcap white sox
nothing
payoff pitch is rifled on a changeup
down into the right field corner
went to the well one too many times
reyes with a good throw it's inside they
got him
oh how about the franimal showing off
the hose in deep right field
[Applause]
i was watching grandalgo out of the
plate and i'll tell you what
those
those feet were moving but he wasn't
going very far but he smokes his change
up here
and it got down into the corner brad
meal took his time
made one hop nice beautiful throw
he didn't rush it
ends up getting
the dh but now at catcher
that's second base and please sack loves
it and that gives to marlo hale
and now it's fran mill reyes who flied
to right his first time up
bouncing ball up the middle and that
gets through
so fred mel reyes drives jose ramirez
into third base with that single into
center field
indians at the corners with nobody out
here in the fourth brad mill hits it on
the ground and then finds a hole
it goes to the backstop coming home is
jose ramirez with the game's first run
reyes moves into second base well they
get their first run on i'm thinking a
pass ball
because that thing didn't hit the dirt
it looked like it had maybe a little run
to it or a cut and collins just flat out
didn't catch it i mean it wasn't in a
great spot right wasn't i mean it was a
little too far outside but it's
catchable 2-2
on the ground flat bounce garcia got it
and sheets on the backhand with a pick
that's our defensive play of the night
he left his feet got up spun
fired to first great stretch toward the
outfield by gavin sheets now miles straw
oh for two has struck out both times
tonight
hey double play line out two
just like that well if you're a clement
you got no shot at that no that's the
one time with two hits and a walk in the
inning and it's 0-2 for vaughn now the
base is loaded two out
three two
into left field andrew vaughn has given
the white sox the lead when this run
comes home and now there's a rundown
brian goodwin is stuck between second
and third he's going to try to get to
second base he's tagged but the white
sox now have the lead and rhubarb with a
big two-out hit
and we go to the bottom of the sixth
it's the white sox two cleveland one
owen miller he doubled in the third
robbed of a hit on a terrific play by
laori garcia to end the fourth inning
there it is line drive centerfield base
it zimmer ties the game hey man it's
coming home with the go ahead rudy is
say
3-2 cleveland oh and miller delivers in
the clutch boy miller has a nice
approach fastball coming in he stayed
short to it
you gotta send him here comes the throw
hamilton all the way in it's awfully
close
and it's a good thing that demarlo
pitched ran out at second base to get
this guy in there because he just beats
it well they're going to challenge the
play
i think he's safe though
i think his hand got in there yes
the boys have loaded them up and nobody
out
slowly hit on the ground to first and no
play anywhere
chang thought about coming home
he never threw it he never really had
the ears on it and the socks have tied
the game with four straight base runners
in the seventh then chang tried to turn
around and throw to first and there was
nobody there if this ball had gotten
away about another foot more billy
hamilton scores from third base kyle
hudson going through the signs at third
mercado stepping out to check them
there it is wet field deep
onto the home run porch and good night
on a day in which chicago clinched the
american league central division title
it ends
on a walk-off home run by oscar mercado
as the indians split the twin bill with
chicago he loved it those first two up
and in i knew when he hit it it was gone
did it stay fair it certainly did
outstanding
you